I was also watching the Olympics
and I realized this when I was watching
the London Olympics
and I was annoyed by how
all the journalists asked all the athletes
the same stupid question
literally, every one ...
"Were you nervous?"
or "Are you nervous?"
whether it was before or after the event.
Every single time.
And every single time all the athletes
gave the exact same answer ...
"No, I was excited."
"No, I'm excited."
Every single time.
These elite athletes had learned to interpret
body stimulus ...
what are the signs of nervousness?
Your heart races, you visualize the future,
your hands get clammy.
What are the stimulus for excitement?
Your heart races, you visualize the future,
your hands get clammy.
They had learned to interpret
what their body was telling them
not as nerves
but as excitement.
And the reason the journalists said,
"Were you nervous?"
is because they would be nervous.
Athletes would never say that to each other.
They'd say, "That was exciting!"
So I tried it.
I did a little test on myself.
I'm on a plane,
we start hitting some really bad turbulence.
I go (gasp)
and then I say to myself,
literally out loud,
"This is exciting!"
And I was fine.
So I do it a lot now.
When I find myself getting nervous
I say to myself,
"This is so exciting"
and I'll explain the reason to myself why.
So, like an actor you don't get nervous
when you go on stage anymore
but occasionally you do.
So I get to go on stage a lot
and I don't really get nervous much anymore
but I was going to
present to 3,000 chiefs of police
right in the middle of all this police
brutality hullabaloo
and I got really nervous because
the stakes were really high
and I was literally getting nervous backstage
and I said to myself,
"This is so exciting.
I have an opportunity
to talk to a group of people who can actually affect change in this country.
This is really exciting."
Now I could have said the same thing,
"I'm so nervous,
I'm about to talk to people who could ... "
but the interpretation was excitement.
Just change the narrative.
It works brilliantly well.